elle devait être la réunion de la
dernière chance elle sera finalement
celle qui enterre définitivement le
projet de la nouvelle prison de lure le
rendez vous parisien de ce matin au
ministère de la justice a vite tourné au
désenchantement pour les élus un vrai
scandale au titre de l'aménagement du
territoire je le répète c'est absolument
détestable
ses méthodes de travail tout va la
france urbaine tout va la concentration
métropolitaine les territoires ruraux
les petites villes se sentent abandonnés
c'est vraiment un scandale et une
déception énorme parce que tous les élus
de haute saône tous bords confondus l'on
travaillait en commun de façon sincère
et il ya eu de l'argent demi déjà dans
des prix alors allure cette annonce a
fait l'effet d'une douche froide puisque
le dossier de la prison était devenue un
symbole fort de la défense des services
publics dans une ville qui a déjà vu
disparaître son tribunal de grande
instance qui a déjà vu des services
fermés à la sous-préfecture ainsi qu'aux
impôts donc le dossier de la prison
était symbolique quant à cette
thématique et ce matin nous avons
rencontré des habitants qu'ils étaient
résignés et inquiets concernant l'avenir
bien sûr c'est dommage parce que le
problème ce qui se passe c'est que ça
ramène quand même toujours à plus il
faut quand même cette ville est fou
comme bien que cette ville
elles vivent à ce moment là si on lui
enlève ça qu'elles sont à lui enlever
demain il y avait des pros mais ce donc
ne tombe pas tenu encore encore une fois
donc ça ne peut pas durer
un dossier qui interpelle d'autant plus
que des frais ont été engagés par l'état
dans le terrain qui avait été choisie
pour accueillir cette future probable
prison qui ne se construira donc jamais
eric hall et le maire de lyon nous
précise qu'il va demander une réunion en
urgence avec le préfet de haute saône
pour je cite demandé des mesures
réparatrices